[Music]
Wonder
for
Transparency
International
project
Freedom
House
for
[Music]
add
for
for in
way thank you very much Madame President
first of all let me say that we strongly
condemn the violent Attacks of September
24th my deepest condolences to the
family and the friends of the police
officer such an attack is totally
unacceptable it clashes with EU values
and and the perpetrators must be brought
to
Justice dear Madame President dear via
um it is good to be here again and thank
you very much for welcoming me here
again in
Christina at the very beginning let me
reassure you that the EU is fully
committed to a future with all six
Western Balan countries as part of our
European
union and looking at Kosovo my first
message is Kosovo is making steady
progress in EU reforms so
congratulations on your hard work and
your efforts especially in uh
strengthening your
democracy with your cross party
electoral reform of course there's more
work to be done as we've just discussed
in our meeting but I want to reassure
you also we will walk this path
together perhaps at the beginning a word
on the Visa
liberalization I remember very well last
year when the two of us were at the
press conference and there was a strong
call for the Visa liberalization now um
this year I would say basically we've
made it um so a big step forward as a
first of January Kosovo citizens will be
able to enjoy Visa free travel to the
European Union like the rest of the
region and we all know this is a
fantastic way to bring our people closer
it is a very important milestone in our
relations so well done um this is a
result of years of hard work uh on the
side of Kosovo I know
it my second message is we have to bring
our economies
closer and this is what we have been
doing in the past you recall we have our
30 billion European investment plan for
the Western Balkans it is delivering
fast for example the railway Corridor 10
that connects you and Serbia and North
Macedonia and the solar for coso
photovoltaic plant that you are
currently preparing beautiful
projects actually also last year we went
together side by side through an
enormous severe energy crisis we
supported you with 75 million euros and
I hope this helped cushion the impact of
High Energy prices on households and
businesses these were very testing times
but we overcame the difficulties
together now as I said we have to bring
our economies
closer and uh if we look at the
figures the economy of Kosovo is at
27% of the EU average income so there's
a lot of untapped
potential and uh we should try to double
your economy within a decade and this is
why we have put forward the growth plan
if I may summarize it very briefly it's
four pillars the first pillar is we open
our single Market in several crucial
sectors to your businesses your
companies in return and this is pillar
number two we expect you to open your
borders for the common regional market
of the western Balkan this is very
important because then we have the
single market and we have the common
regional market which has an enormous
potential actually the common regional
market could increase the GDP of the
western Balkans by 10% if completed so
big incentive there to now the third
pillar says um for this opening of the
markets we need a Level Playing Field
and for that some reforms have to be
done for example for Kosovo improving
the business environment equipping
people with the right skills or Greening
your energy sector you're doing a lot
but we have to do more and of course
there are still very important
horizontal priorities like strengthening
the Judiciary fighting corruption and
organized crime but the fourth pillar is
and this is also new that with the
reforms you are doing comes
investment this is a
principle um we have adopted in the
European Union in our so-called Next
Generation EU plan investment and
reforms and it works very well so if it
works in the European Union's member
state I'm convinced it will also work in
the western Balkan countries so this
growth PR is supposed to boost your
economy most importantly it will create
good jobs and it will support you on
your way um in the accession to the
European Union I believe this is the
right offer at the right time as I said
the plan has the potential to double
your economy within a decade and it will
play an important role on your path to
the European
Union my last
message we all know we only can achieve
all these steps forward and successes if
Kosovo and Serbia normalize their
relations it is absolutely crucial for
both to engage to co operate and we've
discussed the topic together that Kosovo
could launch the procedure to establish
the association of Serb majority
municipalities that is the draft
statement um of last week Serbia should
deliver on Def facto
recognition this is what I will discuss
tomorrow in Serbia and of course the EU
dialogue is the place to um discuss
these topics we're deeply convinced this
is the only way to go forward not only
to access the growth plan but also
towards a future in which coo and we
really hope it's going to happen is part
of the European Union thank you very
[Music]
much uh from Reuters um I want to ask
you over
here I want to ask you how you could
pledge more money to a country where you
have introduced sanctions so is there a
plan to live these sanctions and
probably to add more
sanctions yes indeed what uh the
president and I have discussed and of
course I will discuss it with the prime
minister is um what can we do to lift
the
measures and here is the topic of the
draft Statute in the Cent of the
discussion and um it is a part this is
not very technical what I said but
basically it is an important step
forward in the normalization of
relations between uh Kosovo and Serbia
this is Cru crucial and uh it will of
course also open the door to access to
the growth plan so we're working on it
um this is something where we need both
sides to do their necessary steps
forward step forwards but uh it is also
crucial not only to have the
deescalation but also to move forward on
the path towards the European
[Music]
Union
mhone yes sir otherwise come
here if if it's fine for you
sorry about that uh
[Music]
s
foreign
[Music]
ch
yeah so of course deescalation always
requires that are two uh who comply and
are willing to deescalate and to
normalize you need both parties and
therefore um I will after having been
here in Kosovo travel tonight to
Montenegro but then to Serbia and of
course there I will discuss the steps
that are necessary for Serbia for a def
facto recognition of Kosovo um I will
discuss with the president how this
material could materialize so this is
very important to without any
question
okay
for
[Music]
so it is very important we have good and
complex relationship and the main
discussion point that we have together
with countries of the western Balkan
like Kosovo but also like Serbia is um
how we can work closer to together and
of course the accession potentially to
the European Union and for that basic
principles basic values have to be uh
respected and implemented and therefore
it is the country's Choice whether it
wants to move forward with all the
positive effects it has on the economy
on funding on uh having more business
opportunities so it's a country's
Sovereign Choice whether wants to go the
path with us uh or it chooses
differently so there are lot of
incentives um which you might win and
gain when you move forward and a
principle of the European Union is
normalization of neighbor relations good
neighborly relations we all have our
history the history of enlargement is a
history of countries that had uh we came
out of World War II when we started the
European Union so it is a history of
peace and of reconciliation and of
normalization of relations and therefore
this is a precondition to join the
European Union but as I said there are
many many gains accompanied with it
too
um
[Music]
for
fore
[Music]
foree